hey guys that is the first of August my
name is just and here's your daily dose
of gaming the xbox one summer update is
rolling out and here are some of the
changes I voice on Xbox wire has said
nearly all the features that were
included in the preview are part of the
update those features include the
Cortana voice assistant background music
updates to the interface and brand new
additions like language region
independent and the release of the Xbox
app for iOS and Android currently
background music functionality is only
supported by the pandora app but
Microsoft say more apps including groove
music and I Heart Radio are on the way
the full list of features arriving with
the update check out our story on
gamespot there was a strong sentiments
that Britain leaving the EU could be a
real bad thing and you're planning to
pick up an HTC vive that would be
hearing home right about now as of today
the VR headset will cost around eight
hundred and twenty pounds that's 1018
u.s. dollars at once you include postage
and packaging that's up from 689 pounds
HTC explained if the company
continuously monitors and adjust pricing
to ensure we're providing our customers
with the best value possible due to
recent currency valuations changes and
the current value of the GBP we're
adjusting the price of the HTC vive in
the UK although HTC doesn't outright
site brags it as the cause of change the
value of the pound immediately decreased
following the announcement the Britain
voted to leave the European Union
finally the guy who purchased a leaked
copy of no man's sky for twelve hundred
and fifty bucks on eBay may have already
finished the game the dude who goes by
Damien had
posting up gameplay videos before
stopping to avoid bumming out game
director Sean Murray so he said it
seemed like a cool guy in a lengthy
reddit post Damien revealed he did
indeed reach the center of the universe
which is said to be the end game and
that it took him around 30 hours to do
so other games previously said they
expected plays to get there in between
40 and 100 hours Amy and did stress that
there was still a bunch to do after
reaching the center of the universe and
he added that while he didn't use
exploit he did continuously buy and sell
an in-game item to turn a large profit
and via high-end upgrade which sped up
his progress no man skies gerat on
august nine head to game [ __ ] for
stories on out last two and battlefront
3 these short leave your comments in
that comment box available for you again
tomorrow